let's go to our next caller Pat why
don't we we're taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 our next caller comes to us from
the six one five area code caller what's
your name and where are you calling from
today and feel free to jump right into
your question if you want all right uh
my name is Logan and I'm a calling from
Tennessee great what's on your mind and
I just wanted to ask I know that I'm
sorry go ahead
no yeah that's it go ahead okay I was
just uh calling to ask I noticed that
after the election there was a really
large uptick in left-wing organizations
memberships like socialist alternative
and Democratic Socialist of America and
other organizations and I was wondering
if justice Democrats in the long run are
going to have to adopt more radical
left-wing policies in order to get this
new youth section of the vote been
developing that's policies like worker
ownership of media of the workplace
democratically deciding business
decisions and other things like that
it's a good question I mean number one I
I know that groups like the ACLU have
grown significantly since the election I
just I'm not aware of the groups you're
talking about membership growth but
let's you know let's just take it as
part of the premise of the question that
that is happening I don't really know
what the Justice Democrats positions are
on a lot of these things so it's hard
for me to answer as far as that I mean I
think that the point you're getting at
is a good one which is the Democratic
Party is going to need to move away from
being what I call Democrats incorporate
a Democrat Inc and really incorporate
what are the more emerging ideas of the
younger Democratic voters for two
reasons one that that's a larger and
larger share of the electorate every
election cycle and number two
uh because otherwise they're going to
risk pushing voters towards the
Republican Party or the Libertarian
Party or into not voting at all because
they don't feel that the party
represents them so I think that there's
a big turning point here Pat for
Democrats where I've been talking about
the specific issues that I think they
should look at and of course I've never
been a Democrat but I typically vote for
Democrats when you've got a Democrat in
a Republican that is a viable candidate
I'm way to the left of the main the
average of the Democratic Party the
Democrats need to take some issues and
really take progressive stances on them
here I don't think you can go too far to
the left to where you're getting to this
radical ideology thing that the caller
is suggesting because then you abandon
folks in the middle yes I heart in the
spirit of the party is really this
Bernie Sanders tulsi gabbard wing right
now it was before and all of them yeah
where there's no chance that the
Democratic Party is going to go the way
of an arco socialism right I mean it's
just not going to happen and it's not
clear that that would actually be good
because you may lose more people than
you bring in with that that idea but
it's got to move to the left at least in
terms of its public facing platform and
I think you're you're thinking about it
the right way Logan I hope I've
addressed your question you have you
have and I think you guys are definitely
right where you can't go too far too
fast but um you know who knows maybe in
a generation things will be completely
different
yep all right Logan thanks very much
appreciate the call that is going to do
it for live calls for today thanks to
everybody who called in we will one day
take calls again that I can promise you
folks